Wow là, il vit et respire oh
je pensais que ce serait vraiment amusant de
refaire derrière l'homme et juste d'être une
personne et d'être Walt Disney puis tout d'
un coup vous avez l'idée de oh mais je
dois lancer ça et quelqu'un  doit
devenir Walt Disney, c'était vraiment
une seule personne à laquelle nous pouvions tous
penser, ce serait Tom tu dois m'appeler
Walt mr.  Disney a été mutilé là-dedans,
je veux dire et je ne peux pas jouer une icône,
il est difficile d'imaginer quelqu'un d'autre que
Tom jouant à Walt Disney, c'est tellement
parfait que je ne ressemble en rien à Walt
Disney sur Sam, je pourrais me faire pousser une moustache
et me séparer  cheveux, le travail à accomplir était de
capturer en quelque sorte toute cette fantaisie qui est
dans ses yeux ainsi que toute la perspicacité
qui va avec et monte
sur le mot vers le bas le mot vers le bas ça
monte dessus n'oubliez pas ironique  son emblématique
Walt avait un charisme incroyable, il avait une
façon de parler à la personne en disant qu'ils avaient
vraiment l'impression qu'il leur parlait chaque
fois qu'une personne entre dans un cinéma, ils
se réjouiront qu'ils chanteront
Tom Hanks me souffle de la façon dont il le
fait parce qu'il  a cette personnalité,
il y a quelque chose de Finchley similaire à
la paire d'entre eux et à la qualité de tous les hommes
et pourtant la portée motorisée d'un empereur
c'est incroyable la façon dont il marche la
position du corps la façon dont il tient ses mains la
façon dont il touche sa moustache comment il
exprime les choses et  laisse les phrases se
dérouler à la fin j'adore Mary Poppins tu dois la
partager
sa tête était si pleine d'
idées magnifiques qu'il ne pouvait s'empêcher de rendre
tout le monde enthousiasmé par ce qu'étaient ces
idées
est-ce ce que nous raconte l'histoire est-ce que nous
restaurons  commandez avec imagination quand
j'espère encore et encore et encore
laissez-moi vous le prouver vous